[Musique]
pendant des années on nous a traités
d'angélique d'accord maintenant nous on
traite les autres d' inefficace sur leur
dit tout ce que j'avais fait n'a servi à
rien vous avez renier les libertés tout
le monde et à la fin on en est au même
point qu'au début et parfois pire à la
longueur et c'est là l'autre jour
criminologue
voilà ce qu'il dit depuis la nuit des
temps là qu'en dire là la courbe besset
et remonte depuis 22 puis venant pas de
simplement 2099 depuis quatre mais il a
dit là écoutez franchement c'est
énervant je dire arrête de nier tout
sépare est de nier tout autrement moi
j'arrête l'émission selon une étude
ipsos sopra steria la peine de mort est
aujourd'hui plébiscité par 55% des
français soit 11 points de plus en un an
un record qui va de pair avec la hausse
du sentiment d'insécurité ces derniers
mois à titre personnel je ne partage pas
cette position mais je comprends ce que
disent les français c'est un cri
d'alarmé et il faut que certains qui
sont aujourd'hui en position de décider
les écoutes je n'exclus pas du tout que
marine le pen puisse gagner mais je
pense qu'elle ne peut pas gagner seul
voilà tout simplement parce que dans
notre système d'institutions ne peut pas
gagner sans jouer à l'isi si je pense
qu'elles devront s'engager même si elle
ne le souhaite pas parce qu'elle veut
faire de la politique elle est dans la
politique et les électeurs jugent très
durement
un comportement qui vise finalement
donné des bons points ou des mauvais
points
sans s'engager directement sur le combat
politique et sur le terrain je ne vais
le mettre au service d'un candidat voilà
ces jeunes marine le pen et je me
mettrai au service des idéaux sens
marine le pen met pas au service de jean
ne remettrait pas dans un parti
politique est plus ouvert
est-ce que vous pensez que je vais vous
répondre sérieusement vous pensez que
moi je vous racontais ça je tente mais
c'est bien et ça prouve que vous êtes à
la fois consciencieuse impliqués et aux
nantis mais vous ne répondez pas
renoncer vrai mais oui la france va
prendre le tournant de la 5g parce que
c'est le tournant d'innovation et
j'entends beaucoup de voix qui s'élèvent
pour nous expliquer qu'il faudrait
relever la complexité des problèmes
contemporains en revenant à la lampe à
huile
je ne crois pas au modèle a mis une
caricature grossière du président macron
qui nous fait un débat du niveau du café
du commerce et encore pour balayer du
revers de la main cette discussion
nécessaire autour de cette technologie
qui est selon moi pas un progrès loin de
toute argumentation emmanuel macron à
fermer le débat avec arrogance et mépris
comme si le point de vue de la
convention citoyenne qui a demandé un
moratoire sur la 5g n'avait aucune
importance
il n'y a aucun mépris mais ce qui est
certain c'est que nie en bloc une
technologie parce qu'elle suscite des
débats
c'est pas notre façon de concevoir la
politique et le progrès le prouver c'est
pas forcément d'aller plus vite tout le
temps ça peut être aussi de réfléchir à
ce qu'on veut pour notre société
moi c'est vrai que ce que je veux c'est
plus de lien c'est de l'humanité entre
nous et je ne sais pas si la 5g va nous
apporter ça je ne suis ni écolo ni macro
ni sts vous le savez je suis pour le
progrès technique mais là je dis danger
vraiment danger se tendent avec le co
vite va durer faut tous lucides là
dessus pas la peine de se mentir je
pense que dans cette capacité qu'on a à
se projeter se réinventer dans le second
ce qu'on a appelé le monde d'après mais
qui va être au fond le monde de la vie
avec le virus sans doute pour ed
semestre peut-être des années
nous devons protéger les californiens
lost world qu'elle exhale finira pas se
refroidir
j'aimerais que la science soit d'accord
avec vous je ne pense pas que la scion
sache réellement
que soit la côte
complète cela me gêne
voilà ce que voulait toujours avoir
d'avis et si c'est ça se renouvelle sa
change de rôle